[Müzik]
anlatmak aslında bir tanrı mesleği
Tanrılar anlatır öğüt verir dinleyin
ister ama İnsanoğlu hep anlatılanın
dışına çıkar aynı Adem ve hava gibi ya
hoşuna gider dinlememek ya da dinleyerek
başka şeyler bulur
Ben de bir öğretmen olarak size
bir yatılı okul hikayesini anlatacağım
kozaların nasıl doğduğunu ya da doğmadı
Ece Ayhan'ın şiirini bilirsiniz meçhul
öğrenci Anıtı
buraya bakın buraya bu kara mermerin
altında biri teneffüs daha yaşasaydı
tabiattan tahtaya kalkacak bir çocuk
gömülüdür devlet dersinde öldürülmüştür
kasımın da
daha önce hiç bilmediğim görmediğim bir
yere öğretmen olarak atandım Bingöl'e
ve işte Bu gördüğünüz Yatılı okulda
görev yapmaya başladım
benim için çok farklı bir deneyimdi daha
önce gördüğüm okullardan çok farklıydı
Çünkü bu okul yatılı bir okuldu yatılı
okulları da Leyli mecâni hepiniz
bilirsiniz ama bu okul çok farklı idi 24
saatlik bir yaşam döngüsünde çocuklar
sürekli
okul
yatakhane ve yemekhane üçlüsünde
yaşamlarını geçiriyorlardı
Bir gün şöyle başlıyordu sabah
kalkıyorduk o zamanlar öğretmenler
kravat takıyordu bize çok heyecanlıydık
Bingöl'den yarım saatlik bir yolda Okula
geldik ve çocuklarla dersler başlıyordu
Bu okulda
sıraya girmek bir ritüeldi benim çok
ilgimi çekmişti sabah sıraya giriyorlar
öğlen yemek sırasına giriyorlar akşam
tekrar sıraya giriyorlar Ben çocukların
hep sıralı hallerini bu Okulda gördüm
bir de
akşam olurdu
akşam yatılı okullara ayrı bir hüzünle
gelir Çünkü beyaz minibüsler okuldan
ayrılır
yatılı olanlar sırada onlara bakarlardı
nöbetçi öğretmen Bir Kadın Bir Erkek
Çocuklarla bir arada kalırdı
ve akşamın karanlığı çökünce ki yatılı
okullarda ağlamak Çok da iyi değildir
ama herkesin de bir Ağlama köşesi olur
Bazı çocuklarda ağlardı annelerini ve
babalarını özlüyorlardı
akşam etütler yapılır yemek yenir ki
yemekler genelde öğlenden kalan
yemeklerdir ve etüt yapılır ve
yatakhaneye gidilir Bir de yatakhane
vardır
yatakhanelerde üst katla kız öğrenciler
alt katta erkekler vardır ve
yoğun bir şekilde yaşam alanı orada
başlar
Bir de banyo günü ise
kurnalı hamamlarda öğrenciler yıkanır
çamaşırları da çocuklar yıkar
kıyafetleri de çok öğrenci gördüm
çamaşırhanede uyuya kalmış yorgunluktan
Çünkü bu işler genelde Onların işi
ve öğretmen yatın der
Işıkları kapatır o koşturma kavga
gürültü bir yanda kendini bir hüzne
bırakır
Az önceki o gürültüler artık fısıldıya
dönüşmüştür ve küçük çocuklar ki onlar
tabi Dot boylu çocuklardır şu kadar
çocuklardır tek yatamazlar
ben de nöbetimde bazen yakın akrabaların
yanında yatmalarına izin veriyordu
ağlıyorlardı
Siz hiç ranzasına Anne yazan çocuk
gördünüz mü
ben gördüm
ve çocuklar
kıyafetleriyle yatıyorlardı Bu da beni
çok şaşırtmıştı
Lacivert ceket gri pantolon çorabın
içine geçirilmiş ve çocuklar uyuyorlar
neden diye sorduğumda karınları
acıkıyormuş sabah oyalanmamak ve hızlıca
kahvaltıya gitmek için
yaptıklarını söylüyorlardı Bir de ranza
vardır
ranzaların dili çok değişiktir hele üst
ranza da Yatmak da ayrı bir şeydir
öğrenci üst katta çok yatmak istemez
gece düşme tehlikesi vardır
öğretmenler ilk yarar ve çocuklar öyle
yatardır ve
tutanaklara Bu Gece vukuatsızdır Geçer
ve her gece çok ilginç bir türkü ile
çocukların sayıklamaları
fısıldamaları ve rüyaları birbirine
girerdi
tekrar dolaşır ışıkları söndürürdü
Ağlama seslerini Ben içten içe duvardan
duvara duyuyordum
bu çocuklar özlüyorlardı
annelerini özlüyorlar
dı Siz hiç iki ay Annenizi görmeden
durabildiniz mi
ne yazık ki 3 saatlik 4 saatlik o
coğrafi koşullarda bu çocuklar evlerine
her zaman gidemiyorlardı yıl 1998
ve bir cumartesi ki bu cumartesiler
Bugünün cumartesi
hep beni bir hüzne gark eder
cumartesiler ayrı bir hüzündür
Siz hiç hafta sonunun
hüzünlü olduğunu hissettiniz mi Çünkü
yatılı okullarda öyledir
cuma günü İstiklal Marşı biter
beyaz minibüsler okuldan ayrılır ve
güvercin gibi birbirlerine sarılan
pilavı çocuk kalır
bu Çocuklar 2 gün boyunca
Hafta sonunu geçireceklerdir ve
Hafta sonunu ne kadar ağır olduğunu ne
kadar istenmediğini ben orada anladım
Çünkü o çocuklar orada yalnız
kalıyorlardı
hüzünlü bir hal alıyordu ki o cumartesi
günü neşesi çocuklar yalnız ve yalnız
orada birbirlerine tutunuyorlardı işte
çoğu kimse Pazartesi istemez ama bu
çocuklar O günün gelmesini istiyorlardı
hafta sonu etütler çalışmalar sportif
faaliyetler ve kahvaltı Öğlen yemeği ve
bu çocuklar En çok da zeytin
seviyorlardı bu beni de çok şaşırtıyordu
Bir de öğlen yemeğinde kuru fasulye
varsa Değmeyin keyiflerine o zamanlarda
televizyon eğlence alanları çok yoktu ve
kendi kendilerine zaman geçiriyorlardı
Kürdü zazası Alevisi çok ilginç bir
sosyoloji vardı orada
çok farklı İnsanlar bir aradaydı Ama
bunlar çocuktu birçok şeyden farkı yoktu
farkında değillerdi Tabii 4 boyu kadar
çocuklarla
15-16 yaşında orta bir öğrenci ile bir
aradaydı Okuma yazmayı unutanlardan
Tutun da hiç eline kalem almayanlar da
size bir yatılı Okulu anlatıyor
16 Mart 1999
yine o hafta sonunun verdiği hüzünle
beraber
küçük öğrencim Cihan ki Kınalı saçlıdır
gözleri sürmelidir
beni çok severdi ve çok etrafımda
dolaşırdı
ben çoğu zamanda bunu anlamazdım ama
sonradan anladım ki Cihan babasını
özlüyor
annesini özlüyordu evini özlüyordu
Martın o boranında
kış ve karında
Cihan Ferhat ve Serhat
bir kuş gibi bu okuldan
kaçma planı yaptılar
büyük bir kar yağmakta
ve
yatakhaneden çıkan o kaloriferin Sisi
aslında gelecek felaketi de bize belki
söylüyordu
çocuklar plan yaptılar
yoklamadan sonra gideceklerdi nereden
Çıkacaklarını da planlamışlardı
ceplerine de kahvaltıdan aldıkları kuru
ekmek ve zeytinleri koydular
ve okuldan kaçtılar
bir Boran bir kar tipi büyük bir
soğuk
hala iliklerimle hissederim
3 saatlik
Sütlüce yoluna revan oldular
bu 3 güvercin yolda
Best mezrasında
Tipiye tutuldular
öyle bir tipi ki öyle bir soğuk
güvercinler birbirlerine sarılı halde
cesetlerine ulaştılar
bu çocuklar
orada
yok oldular
bulunduklarında üçü de
birbirlerine sarılıyorlardı sarılmış
buldular
planları eğer işleseydi o tipi de o
Ayazda o karda ölmemiş olsalardı
annelerinin sıcak kucağına gideceklerdi
ve arama ekipleri onları bulduğumda
üç çocuğun cebinden de zeytin taneleri
çıkmıştı
Evet
yine bir cumartesi
İşte bu kahrolası cumartesi
benim nöbetimde
Cihan'ın annesi geldi
ancak ağlıyordu annenin feryadını orada
gördüm
Siz hiçbir Annenin kendini parçaladığını
gördünüz mü
Bir annenin göğü deldiğini gördünüz mü
bana anlamadığım dilde bir şeyler
söylüyordum
bana ağıt yakıyordu ve ben
orada
ağıtın dilinin olmadığını anladım
kulaklarımda o 3 güvercinin
Kürtçe Zazaca Türkçe İmdat sesleri
yankılanıyordu ve anne
o Kınalı Kuzu Cihan'ın eşyalarını
oradaki çocuklara dağıttı
dağıtırken hem
onlara sarıldı hem de o eşyalarını
kokladım
bu öyle bir acı ki
o kozanın yok oluşunu da orada gördüm
bu cumartesinin
O sabahın verdiği hüznü hiç unutma Cihan
şimdi yaşasaydı
32 yaşında olacaktı Belki bugün
saatlerde çocuklarıyla kahvaltı
yapacaktım Fakat o Koza orada söndü
ama
bazı kozaları da ben daha sonra gördüm
yıllar sonra Profesör olduğumda
İstanbul'da bir konferans verirken
çıkışta iki tane çocuk geldi yanıma
Hocam bizi hatırladın mı dediler
Ben hatırlayamadım
Meğer benim de ders verdiğim çocuklarmış
o kozalardan bir kısmı Yitik giderken
bir kısmı da canlanıp hayallerine
kavuşmuş
Bu yüzden
yatılı okur bir kurşun gibi ağırdır
yatılı okul
Ece Ayhan şiiri kadar Derindir ve
oradaki kozalara hepimizin destek olması
gerekmektedir Selam ve saygılar
[Alkış]